desde el estadounidense Joe biden hasta
el cubano Miguel Díaz canel los líderes
mundiales han felicitado a receta Jeep
erdogan por su triunfo en la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones en Turquía los
presidentes de países de distintas
latitudes remarcaron el deseo de seguir
estrechando lazos como es el caso del
mandatario francés en Manuel macron
quien destacó los desafíos que se vienen
para París y ankara Francia y Turquía
tienen grandes desafíos que enfrentar
juntos el regreso de la pasa de Europa
el futuro de nuestra Alianza
euroatlántica el mar Mediterráneo con el
presidente erdogan a quien felicito por
su reelección Seguiremos avanzando
además de la Esfera política hubo
celebraciones civiles en algunas
ciudades como Londres y Bruselas Pero
uno de los sitios donde más festejo subo
fue en gaza donde habitantes palestinos
se alzaron con la victoria de erdogan
cuyos gobiernos aboga por una solución
en el conflicto palestino israelí y
condenan a la ocupación en sijordania
dentro de jamás esperamos reforzar el
apoyo Turco a la lucha legítima de
nuestro pueblo contra la ocupación y más
ayuda para nuestro pueblo a fin de
asegurar su lugar en la tierra en la
búsqueda de la lucha por la libertad el
establecimiento en el estado palestino
con Jerusalén como su capital
la administración de erdogan tiene por
delante asuntos internacionales que debe
resolver como la aprobación de la
petición de Suecia para entrar a la
Unión Europea o continuar con la
mediación del acuerdo de granos entre
Rusia y Ucrania